do you ever
give it because
you know when you when you first start
making money on youtube it's exciting
yeah right you're doing he's like oh my
god i made a hundred bucks yeah it's
crazy it's insane and then you're really
proud because you're like oh my god i
can get paid for doing this thing that i
love yeah you know and then for the
first two years i was making enough to
maybe buy myself a movie ticket yeah
because
ten thousand dollars
you know the first year i think i only
made like five hundred dollars from it
yeah
second year probably made like five
thousand dollars still not enough to
live off but you know i was like wow
it's so exciting right and then it goes
up and it scales up and that's when i
think you start to feel bad about how
much money you're making yeah right yeah
do you ever get like imposter syndrome
about it yeah of course i think
everything i think most
nearly every youtuber yeah get impostor
syndrome yeah the reason why a lot of
youtubers don't want to talk about that
money is because a lot of them feel bad
i think yeah
i don't think they should right i wish
we lived in a system where no one gave a
[ __ ] about money and people could be
more honest about it and that people
could because then i think that would
make sense that's why i'm glad this
twitch thing came out because now yeah
people are like wearing their [ __ ]
earnings with on their badges yeah well
because i think that it makes a
better atmosphere for everyone to be
able to negotiate for better like pay in
their job
you know there's a like in traditional
jobs there's sometimes even though
they're not allowed to ask you to do
this the bosses will be like don't talk
about how much money you're making yeah
but you're allowed to but people don't
because they're scared and they don't
want to they don't want to be judged but
if you're doing the exact same thing as
your colleague whether it be on twitch
or in the same job you should be able to
argue that you should be valued the same
way they are yeah and it's one of those
things where when i meet other content
creators um in private i'll ask them
like how much did you get for the
sponsorship deal yeah and i'll be like
what did you get because i want to make
sure you didn't get [ __ ] over yeah
because i know how much you should be
getting because because like speaking
from people
people in the industry no one nobody
teaches each other and one of the
stupidest things that a lot of content
creators don't talk to each other about
this even though the more content
creators you talk to the more you
realize oh a lot of people are getting
[ __ ] because they've never talked to
any other content creator about this
yeah taking deals that like for example
i like i took a deal for a sponsor on a
video this is when i was getting around
about an average fifty thousand to a
hundred thousand views i took a
sponsorship for a hundred dollars
what and the video got half a million
views that's not that's not worth it by
the way something a video let's say when
you're about if you have fifty thousand
to a hundred thousand average views you
should probably getting what about maybe
two thousand to four thousand dollars
yeah at least 20 to 50 times yeah yeah
which sounds like a lot i know i know
that sounds like a lot to a lot of
people um but this is advertising space
right this is eyeballs that you're
getting so you have to think of it like
that um so you can you can naturally i
mean i guess that's where our knowledge
comes in right where it's it's not like
that's not a set number because it all
it all depends on the client it all
depends on the product you're promoting
some clients in certain spaces are
willing to
uh are willing to sell you like this
spot for a higher price some aren't yeah
it's
yeah it's it's really comes down to
experience but
if you're a content creator you should
really be talking to other content
creators if you have no idea what to
charge a client right if you have no
idea then i've like because here's the
thing i've searched up
i've searched up uh like before like
youtube of like how much you should be
charging
certain clients and and like
all the youtubers i've seen who have
said how much you you should be charging
have got the have got the number wrong
you know and that's because a lot of
them aren't aren't big creators
and like the numbers the numbers really
depend on where you are on youtube and
it really comes down to experience and
what your other p what other people are
doing in your fields which really
depends on how much you can charge right
so i i feel like i feel like talking to
you guys about it
before we we are now able to charge more
because we've realized that we're all
getting charged different prices yeah
for certain it's it's also not just
about like the the sub count and like
view count stuff like that so i feel a
lot of it especially nowadays that like
companies are looking for is like
branding power yeah but you could have
the like two channels could have the
exact same number of subs and views but
yeah one could be a stronger brand and
that depends on the in and of itself
right yeah and it depends on like the
audience and the demographic so there's
so many components that go into it it's
not just like a bare bones like
i get this many views on average
therefore i should be getting this
amount of money like yeah it's
completely case by case which which is
like my general advice to anyone who is
independent and not even a youtuber but
an artist right we've had to learn
what our value is that's that's the
biggest thing you have you have to like
you have to know what your value is and
not be ashamed and not be ashamed when
they ask about how much it costs
when it comes to negotiations with a
company or with a fellow client you
can't be ashamed to big up your value
because
you are bringing something for them
right you are you are bringing something
to the table and you need to articulate
that nothing hurts me more than seeing
an artist underselling themselves oh man
it hurts so much so it's so it hurts me
so much like i always make sure like if
i'm working with an artist i'm like
you sure you want that much like i can
give you more i think you're worth a
little bit more than that you got you
have a little bit of confidence in
yourself yeah like exactly like you
can't be scared to like
obviously you can't like ask for an
egregious amount at a small price but
you know there is a limit that you can
go and it's okay to step over that limit
even slightly just to get your name out
there you know if you really believe in
your work um but yeah just oh my god
i've seen so many [ __ ] artists just
be like yeah i'll give you like this
amount and it's like a tenth of what i
was envisioning it's like uh yeah i
don't know if you want to do that too
yeah like
be a little more confident in yourself
you know and i think another thing that
a lot of people don't talk about when it
comes to like the economics of youtube
and like getting getting paid for this
as a job is that is the amount of time a
lot of content creators will go before
they get big doing work and not getting
paid and not doing this for money i mean
i i did youtube for like seven eight
years before i saw my first paycheck
right um and especially in especially
nowadays it's a super super competitive
industry in a super super competitive
field so my like whenever someone comes
to me and asks me for advice about how
to make youtube a job i i the first
thing i ask them is do you have the time
to take a year off you a year off in
your life without getting paid and
working a night like working harder than
a nine-to-five job yeah because that's
like that's the minimum sacrifice you
will have to do nowadays to unless
you're like super super lucky to do
youtube and even if you do that you
might not even get popular you might
you know it might not even come to
fruition so are you willing to take to
make that sacrifice in your life for a
chance to have this as a job which is
why like i feel very lucky to have this
position yeah but you know i i did i i
do you know i do know that i there was
some portion of luck within my career
path but also
everyone i've met including all three of
us worked super [ __ ] hard as well we
went through a point where we were
working harder than a 95 job without
getting paid or being paid like less
than minimum wage to get where we are
and we did that for about a year and i
feel like i feel like a lot of people
who are maybe older
who are more established to be like you
know i got a nine-five job i can't
really take a year out in my life that's
why a lot of youtubers you see start off
in like college or in high school when
you do have that time and
all i can say to that is i'm you know
i'm sorry that's just the way it works
you can't you can't like it's it's it's
not a company youtube youtube isn't like
youtube you're not a paid salary man you
know it's yeah i mean like as an example
it's like you know like mr beast like
jimmy was
barely got any views for like the first
like six seven years of his career and
then all of a sudden he's he's that
where he's at now right but like i think
what a lot of people forget is that he
didn't just come out of nowhere he
didn't just make a video and it
immediately you know get him 50 million
subs right it's like he takes a long
time he worked for that [ __ ] it takes a
very long time yeah and that's the thing
that everyone wants to gloss over yeah
and that's not me just trying to justify
why people should make 50 [ __ ]
million dollars a year but yeah it's
just
you should you can't criticize it
without first understanding that and
appreciating that it does sometimes take
a [ __ ] ton of work yeah you know and uh
the one thing uh that people love to
forget is that life is not fair
you know it's like it's it's not it's
not a fair system right now
you know you could put
just as many hours if not more hours
into playing guitar or something and
nothing could come of it yeah i mean
think of the the hundreds and thousands
of guitarists
like you also have to unders like i
think
one thing that is kind of
oversold in life is that if you put x of
hours into something it'll just work out
yeah and it's not always that it's not
always that simple you know if you're
getting into something that is
extremely popular worldwide yeah it's
going to be way harder than if you're
for example making anime videos on a
website called youtube in 2015. yeah
i
i mean it's differences in scale of what
you're trying to compete you know i'm
sure everyone on will everyone in the
world started doing the type content
that we were doing i think we'd be out
of a job pretty soon because no doubt
there'd be other people who are better
than us that would happen but that's not
but not everyone is doing it that's
necessary i mean i feel that's why it's
called a dream job for a reason right
yeah i mean i mean like i i did take a
[ __ ] massive risk with my career
choices you know because back then
when i had a steady paid job i had a
career path i could pursue and i like
did you work out again i i worked at the
bbc did you know that did you know that
she
[Laughter]
no because yeah i did i did sacrifice
that a proven career path for an
industry that was not proven that an
industry that didn't exist back then
that i i that wasn't proven where that i
could do this more than a year or two
and i took a risk that it was going to
turn out to something and i was lucky
enough that it did turn out you know
um nowadays it's a different ballgame
you know i i i took that risk with my
career path if you want to be a youtuber
or a twitch streamer you have to take a
different risk and it's it's a different
risk but
the risk to rewards is like the rewards
are there to be seen and that's why
people take risks to get that reward
the the one lucky thing about youtube
and twitch is that you can do in your
downtime you know you can put a little
bit of effort here and there yeah see
some results see that there's a demand
for it and then dedicate more time to it
that is one good thing about it like you
know yes you're you're going to be a
disadvantage if you are working like god
said and you are 30 plus and you've got
a life that you need to maintain yeah
but it's not impossible like there is so
there are some ways it's not impossible
and there are cases where it has worked
out again yeah it's just harder and the
the playing field isn't level but it
never is yeah um no you know uh i'm sure
that if you uh let's say you just had a
friend who was a big youtuber you're
already at a massive advantage because
they can help you out oh yeah or you
have a family history of using cameras
or editing you know like there's all
kinds of variations of advantages but
that's [ __ ] life yeah i feel like i
could apply with any job